on reçoit tout de suite Caroline
saineville qui est présidente de la CSN
bonsoir Caroline et François Vincent qui
est le vice-président pour le Québec de
la Fédération canadienne de l'entreprise
indépendante bonsoir Pour ou contre les
baisses d'impôts ça ressemble un peu à
ça notre table ce soir je vous pose la
question d'abord pourquoi vous dites non
à la CSN obèse d'impôts pour lesquels
les Québécois ont voté quand même et que
le gouvernement envisage pour le 21 mars
ce que les services publics sont en
périls carrément puis je pense que si on
avait posé les la question aux gens
est-ce que vous êtes pour des baisses
d'impôts où vous êtes pour les
investissements dans le service public
vraiment honnêtement je me demande ce
qu'elles auraient été la réponse est-ce
que vous trouvez que la question est
orientée mais c'est sûr qu'en contexte
d'inflation quand on se dit ben
j'aimerais savoir de l'argent dans mes
poches la tarte aux pommes il y a 165
000 au Québec 165 000 personnes au
Québec qui attendent une opération
là-dessus il y en a 20 000 que ça fait
plus d'un an je pense que sans poser la
question ces personnes-là voulez-vous
être opéré plus tôt ou avoir une baisse
d'impôts de 109 dollars
ça dépend de la question qu'on pose
François Vincent dans ce cas si vous
dites en contexte d'inflation les gens
vivent de l'inflation à peu près tout le
monde est d'accord avec une baisse
d'impôt mais on a posé plus qu'une
question de demander ce que vous pensez
que c'est un impact positif sur
l'économie est-ce que vous pensez que ça
va vous aider dans le contexte
d'inflation mais moi j'avais
l'impression que je jouais encore plus
le jeu et pas de pouvoir avoir une
réponse négative en allant de cette
façon là avec des questions six pour
pour les PME puis il faut je pense vous
remettre les choses en contexte parce
que le gouvernement du Québec ce qui
propose c'est de réduire
l'investissement dans le fond des
générations pour pouvoir baisser l'impôt
des particuliers donc il y a pas
d'impact sur les services publics la
diminution des services publics puis
avec vos tableaux ça va faire en sorte
qu'on va améliorer la fiscalité aussi
des individus quand on regarde dans
l'ensemble au graphique c'est de la page
60 du document de la chair publique de
la fiscalité on est dans le top 3 de
l'OCDE peut-être plus imposé et c'est ça
peut-être un dernier élément en 2018
puis 2021 l'association des économistes
démontrent qu'on a investi 27% de plus
par habitant dans les services publics
donc on investit davantage on investit
et quand le gouvernement dit on touche
pas aux revenus de l'État dans le fond
parce que ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
prend une partie des versements au fond
des générations là c'est comme si on
disait mais on va être sur notre aire
d'aller dans les services publics la
broche va rester approcher après
l'hôpital me raisonne Maisonneuve
heureusement le DPCP va être encore en
train de décider quel cas qu'on apporte
devant la cour puis pas parce que on
manque de personnel de bureau carrément
dans les tribunaux la santé mentale va
pas s'améliorer les écoles ne serait-ce
que la qualité de l'air on est est-ce
qu'on est en train de dire tout va très
bien Madame la marquise on a fait la
commission Laurent ils sont pas capables
de mettre en place les recommandations
de la commission Laurent la DPJ et de la
difficulté à se dépêtrer puis à rendre
les services qu'elle doit rendre alors
si le constat était que tout va très
bien donc c'est de l'argent
supplémentaire que ça prend pour régler
tous les problèmes que vous ident de
l'humain pour le bien d'organisation ou
des problèmes de structure à l'intérieur
des organisations non non mais c'est à
dire que probablement qu'on gagnerait à
travailler la structure mais il manque
de proposer aux bénéficiaires il manque
d'infirmières il manque d'enseignants il
manque de personnels les écoles le corps
des écoles les corps déclare sous la
qualité de guerre est pas bonne c'est
c'est pas une vie de l'esprit ça même
identifier on en parle tous les jours
ces problèmes existent en santé en
éducation dans les systèmes sociaux
est-ce que le 2 milliards que l'État
est-ce que ce 2 milliards qui serait en
baisse d'impôts ne serait pas mieux ce
serait pas plus utile dans ce qui est
écrit par Madame Sylvie ce que ça va
mieux aujourd'hui que 10 ans
pas nécessairement est-ce que ça passe
nécessairement par une augmentation du
Fardou fiscal donc j'ai une question
combien on va augmenter les taxes des
citoyens pour être capable de répondre
aux demandes par rapport si si on est
passé c'est quoi la proposition
syndicale on lui demande de combien les
taxes aux citoyens deuxième élément il
faut augmenter les taxes ce qu'on dit
c'est qu'au lieu de prendre 2 milliards
qui iraient au service de la dette puis
on parle de d'équité
intergénérationnelle mais les jeunes qui
grandissent là ils n'ont pas besoin d'un
compte en banque bien garni ont besoin
d'une orthophoniste dans la classe ils
ont besoin des deux puis si on a une
fiscalité avantageuse c'est bon aussi
par rapport à l'équité
intergénérationnels puis faut améliorer
nos services mais penser en dehors de la
boîte une des choses pour l'améliorer
peut-être la première chose c'est
d'aller à la table de négociation avec
le gouvernement pour voir comment on
peut dans le dossier des négociations
qui est quand même très important mais
quand on parle d'équité interne
générationnelle de réduire les
versements au fond des générations et de
réduire donc les revenus de l'État en
baissant les impôts est-ce qu'on pense
vraiment aux prochaines génération quand
on fait ce que oui puis ils font des
génération j'y crois j'ai signé une
lettre ouverte en 2005 pour demander la
création du front des générations à ce
moment-là c'était le 24 novembre 2005
Lyon 2006 c'était 584 millions
d'investissement qui avait du fond après
on a mis d'autres fonds dédiés qui vont
au fond des générations des rendus à 3
milliards on a atteint l'objectif par
rapport à la dette pour le PIB puis si
on continue comme ça en 26 27 on va être
rendu à 5,7 milliards dans le fond des
générations donc là on fait quelque
chose avec une partie déversements on
peut pas tout mettre dans le fond des
générations les impôts sont baissés puis
ça va mal puis on sait qu'on est dans un
contexte d'insécurité de des certitudes
financières on nous dit que ça va être
très certainement ralentissement sinon
même une récession qu'est-ce qu'on fait
quand ça va mal on l'irmant on les
augmente pas les services les impôts je
m'excuse qu'on va faire c'est ce qu'on a
fait il peut avoir des décennies c'est
baisser la qualité des services et ce
qui c'est ce qui nous a amené là ce qui
nous a amené là c'est des décennies de
négligence c'est décennie de dire on est
trop taxé c'est des décennies de dire de
parler de fardeau ben on investit
davantage dans les programmes que dans
les autres provinces on a une impôt
progressif assez important par rapport
aux autres provinces on peut créer une
équité générationnelle puis donner plus
d'espace aux citoyens puis leur donner
la possibilité d'économiser la
possibilité d'avoir de l'argent payer
leur hypothèque qui va augmenter si on
est en récession on n'est pas en
récession on est en déficit budgétaire
c'est le bon moment baisser les impôts
même si on est en déficit budgétaire
c'est jamais le bon moment pour les
opposants c'était pas le bon moment en
98 quand Bernard Landry les a déposés
parce qu'encore une fois quand on est
pris dans la difficulté de donner des
services publics on les augmente pas les
impôts qu'est-ce que vous dites madame
Senneville aux gens qui disent on est
très imposés on paye beaucoup de taxes
beaucoup d'impôts au Québec
contribution réduites ce que je dis
c'est que vous avez l'enseignement
collégial à peu près gratuit vous avez
des bourses d'études au lieu d'avoir
juste des
dans les autres provinces on a un Régime
québécois d'assurance parentale alors
que d'ailleurs on voit importer alors
c'est ça aussi et la santé
donc on a les moyens selon vous de faire
les deux je pense pas qu'on a les moyens
de ne pas baisser la fiscalité puis de
de ne pas faire confiance au ministre
des Finances pour gouvernement logo qui
ont une grosse majorité je pense qu'il
faut faire confiance aux individus il y
en a 64% qui sont qui sont en faveur je
pense qu'ils vont prendre des bons choix
moi j'ai confiance aux indices le
gouvernement voulait absolument la
maternelle 4 ans on était là comme ce
matin dire ça marchera pas il manque de
locaux il manque de prof deux ans plus
tard il est obligé de revenir sur sa
décision ok alors budget 21 mars pour la
suite des choses madame c'est une ville
merci Monsieur Vincent merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir merci bien pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI